we're here look okay so i was watching
you at the premiere seeing you doing the
late night rounds like
this life looks good on you buddy
like you're you're doing it it's amazing
i'm glad it comes off that way because
literally it's it's all happening so
fast like every it's like it's like a a
lifetime's worth of milestones condensed
into like a week basically it's like i
haven't even had time to process having
the world premiere of the movie at the
el capitan theater and then and then i'm
like
on kimmel it was it's it's it's crazy
it's wild it's awesome
by the way i just haven't thank you
thank you well i was like see moose cut
here so i gotta come on um i mean that's
the way it is uh you know i asked you
this when you were
kind of in the middle of filming it and
the idea was like is this everything
that you dreamed
and now that you've got the chance to
see people reacting to the film like the
film is is is out there you've got
people giving their impressions like is
everything that you dreamed
it's uh it's so much it's so much more
in a way like that there's just so much
and so many memories and things that i'm
noticing that i really never expected to
um and and don't get me wrong also like
a lot of anxiety that comes with it and
and nerves especially
you know
because of the pandemic you know there's
just so much uncertainty surrounding it
all but but
regardless of all of that i think i
think it was just such a relief and such
a joy to finally be able to share this
movie with the world and getting the
first reactions and having them be as
positive as they are
um really beyond beyond anything that
i've ever that i've ever dreamed of
because you know i i dreamed of of being
a superhero i didn't actu i've never
dreamt of
i never dreamt about you know the world
reacting to it and and potentially being
changed by
you know what what
the story that we were telling and
that's really profound
and it's quite clear that you know you
and this character are right there in
the middle of this entire universe of
superheroes and the possibilities are
endless and i gotta ask you because
you know
karaoke plays a big part in the movie as
it plays a big part in my life and i'm
sure yours too absolutely if you if you
were gonna go on a bender and do karaoke
with any of the avengers
like who is your best karaoke partner
you think oh god that's really good um
oh um feel like
you know i i feel like for some reason
my mind i really want to say yelana
because she's just like i feel like
she's just so sarcastic and dry and like
and i feel like she would just have a
couple of really a she would have an
incredible sense of humor but b she
would just like
know all of like the old songs but also
the new songs and she would just like i
don't know i i think she'd be down for a
good time
buddy i gotta tell you how much i love
this movie like it's all the things and
i was talking to florian and he was
saying how amazing of a martial artist
he thinks that you are do you look at it
and go like
that was me i can't believe i pulled
that off
yeah
yeah definitely i mean the beautiful
thing about about movies is that you
only have to do it right one time
um and and we have some really really
intricate action sequences in this movie
like some really really long takes
some
really you know very acrobatic maneuvers
and um it took a lot of prep to be able
to do those things it's a it's such a
credit to our incredible stunt team that
that you know for for designing the
sequences first of all but also you know
i had to
i had to go and actually practice the
thing and actually do it it's uh it
man it is it is pretty cool having
pulled it off to be on the other side of
that and knowing that i don't have to
wake up the next day and do more of it
is pretty awesome
well buddy i can't wait to catch up in
person and uh talk about this some more
congratulations for now i'll see you
next time thanks man
you